la table va être sur mon plein avec
différentes nationalités des américains
des espagnols des italiens et des
français
une quinzaine de passionnés de golf sont
attendus dans cette maison d'hôtes basée
à magny les hameaux pendant la semaine
de la ryder cup
l'établissement est complet nous allons
mettre les bouchées double triple
quadruple pour qu' il soit ils repartent
avec un souvenir inoubliable de cette
manifestation service de transfert
jusqu'au parking situé à
toussus-le-noble location de vélos la
responsable de cette maison d'hote a
tout préparé
et cela depuis plusieurs années les
personnes me contacter depuis plus de
sept ans et j'ai pris des des noms aux
des mails et des pré réservations mais
je n'ai rien réservé à une bonne assise
a ouvert les réservations le 30
septembre 2017 lui jours après c'était
complet les tarifs ont été multipliées
par deux c'est le casseur de toutes les
réservations chaque personne j'ai fait
une une possède par personne qui a
réservé le nombre de chambres les
nombres de nuit qu'il souhaite pour les
accueillir au mieux et ben je vois
exactement qui arrive quand qui
souhaitent un transfert qui souhaitent
un vélo les hôtels vont également faire
le plein pendant la ryder cup sur saint
quentin en yvelines et dans les
agglomérations environnantes
cet événement est quand même très
positif en hausse sur le territoire déjà
pour la visibilité du territoire au
niveau touristique et puis au niveau
hébergements hôtels c'est un plus
bien sûr les hôtels sont quand même très
très remplis près de 70000 spectateurs
sont attendus chaque jour au golf
national durant la semaine de la ryder
cup